[Musique]
au bout de cette rue du quartier de
savannah le département inaugure une
nouvelle structure alors ici monsieur le
préfet vous avez donc le nouvel espace
avec des aménagements annexes qui sont
faits à partir du boîtier y aviez est
juste à côté de boules à l'arrière
puisque nous sommes propriétaires de ces
espaces
on va installer un atelier bois de
goyavier ici à savannah de façon à
pouvoir travailler sur une stratégie
d'aménagement global du site est prévue
ce bâtiment est une première étape qui a
nécessité six cent mille euros
d'investissement un grand pas selon les
agents de la réserve qui travaillent au
quotidien dans cette grande zone humide
480 niveau l'espace tous à skis avant
dans une maison qui était très vraiment
très serré et le patient qu'il est
innocent plus d'hygiène aussi on va dire
on va pouvoir plus travailler aussi
croix entourée d'arbres endémiques
représentant la grande biodiversité de
ce territoire naturel ce lieu devient un
outil essentiel de développement
c'est un outil dédié bien sûr à
l'accueil du public parce que les gens
ont besoin de savoir c'est quoi la
réserve ou sait qu'on a les locaux de la
réserve donc on visualise la réserve
c'est un espace de travail aussi pour
les 22 25 agents de la réserve
et quand je passe j'entends les hommes
nationale belchior comment il fait pour
avoir un petit coeur on veut faire du
canoë kayak seul l'étang saint paul
comme on veut et bien vous pourrez venir
ici faire vos réservations à savannah
dans les locaux de la réserve tous sont
unanimes
cet outil est un nouvel élan un rôle et
aux nombreux usages on a déjà énormément
visiteurs sur la réserve en fait mais
ils sont répartis peut guider peu de peu
de zones où identifier on voit
énormément de personnes vont estimée à
cent mille personnes le nombre de
personnes qui viennent visiter les temps
dans l'année donc on est autant qu'une
maison du volcan
fraîchement rénovés ou donc c'est quand
même des sites très important on pense
qu'on peut faire plus de gens mais en
les canalisant les en leur offrant
quelque chose qui soit de nature à
permettre un développement du territoire
réhabilitation de la grande maison de
savannah réhabilitation des viviers
valorisation agricoles et apicoles
situent en périphérie de la réserve bien
des projets sont à venir dans l'un des
espaces naturels sensibles de notre
département
[Musique]